[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him what a bunch of
losers
so Donald Trump doesn't even have to
show up to the debate to win against
these [__]
fools it's
hilarious re ramaswami wants to build a
wall and make Canada pay for it
apparently H every single one of them
wasn't watching the election results
from Tuesday every single one of them's
like yeah
Democrats want to kill babies out of the
womb and [__] just absolute outright
lies the reason the lies that they keep
telling the reasons why they're losing
it's incredible and what's incredible
this morning what's incredible this
morning is watching M brazinski
absolutely [__] shred Chris Christie
now I
am normally a very strong critic of ma
and it's probably because and if you're
listening it's probably because Joe is
always stepping on you and Joe's saying
a lot of stupid [__] Joe scarber that is
her husband and her co-host on Morning
Joe because I you know M again I I don't
want seeing a guy maybe you know there's
something we can't see but here's the
thing is that you going after person in
power like you did this morning with
Chris Christie that's how you're
supposed to do it now I would have went
a bit
further but it is absolutely telling
when I show you this clip of Chris
Christie being totally [__] toned
deaf and even when Ma it it's obvious
that he here's this
[__] politician a
man who was the governor of New Jersey
folks the governor for two terms he was
the [__] Governor he had a chance to
I I don't know what do you call it when
you're Governor change the um what are
those called
laws even Chris Christie a republican
who was elected
twice in New
Jersey claims that the laws are bad in
New Jersey and and the laws allow a
mother to murder their baby which is not
the law folks that's not the [__] law
he's a ling sack of
[__] it's all [__] lies
and she calls him out on the lies now
again in my world it would be a little
different with Chris Christie because my
world would be PR peppered with
profanity to be fair to M she can't
exactly curse on Morning Joe that's one
of the reasons why the media needs to
move aside and let real commentary
happen in this country the way that it
needs to happen we are not going to get
rid of fascism without going at him with
A Hard Punch here
I don't know if you noticed
that but when they go low we go high is
not going to
work I hate to disappoint Michelle Obama
but it's not going to work with
fascist they they're gonna play dirty
because they're dirty [__]
they're pieces of trash their pieces of
garbage like Chris Christie that line
sack of
[__] and I know everyone wants to you
know bow down at the feet of Christie
because he speaks out against Trump but
[__] that [__] that should be the bare
[__]
minimum that should be the bare [__]
minimum we should not be giving credit
to anyone who is doing the bare [__]
minimum okay a lot of people get upset
that I go after Liz Cheney and Adam
kinger well Tony they were on the select
committee I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] doing the bare minimum is
not the standards that we should hold
our public officials or former public
officials are people who are trying to
be the president of the United
States the bare minimum is not a
standard that we should be bowing down
to just because it's a [__] scumbag
Republican come on [__] out of here and
she points this out in this
clip I'm gonna show you this clip and
it's it's about three minutes long and
we're going to go through it step by
step
and I I feel that it's necessary and the
reason why it's necessary is because
people in this country need to
understand that even someone who is his
anti or pretends and is paid to be
anti-trump like Chris Christie because
let's face it that's the [__] case
Chris Christy isn't that anti-trump [__]
him he would do a lot of the same [__]
that Trump would want to do the
[__] shut down a bridge and kill
people in an ambulance for crying out
[__] loud give me a [__] break you
don't think that Chris CHR wouldn't
weaponize government against you against
his political enemies to own the [__]
Libs get the [__] out of here of course
he would he's a goddamn Republican
they're all this way uh speaking of that
of owning the libs and a clip of
Republicans I'm gonna show you a clip of
Eric swell oh my God just [__]
watting Jim Jordan up and dunking him in
the [__] trash Oh it's
beautiful it's beautiful and Jim
Jordan's never going to be able to walk
away from this just like he can't walk
away from the subpoenas that he ignored
and he defied speaking of
subpoenas speaking of subpoenas James
qanon comr you remember this
[__] I know it's been months
since we talked about this stupid son of
a [__] because he's been hamstring by
by not having a speaker of the house
with his little [__] lies
apparently oh my God he subpoenaed
James
Biden that's right not the President
James Biden his
brother for for writing a check for
$200,000 to pay back a loan Joe Biden
gave
James he subpoenaed him to the
weaponization committee or whatever the
[__] stupid ass committee that they got
the rake committee that's what we should
call it the rake stepping committee that
one and really they're all rake stepping
committees they're all R stepping commit
they can't do anything but [__] lose
can they oh my God they don't get it
they don't get it when you're steeped in
lies in your entire Foundation of your
political party and your ideology is
just the whole Foundation is lies it
doesn't work out very well for you
especially when you have people like me
and people like you pointing this [__]
out and the way that we pointed out and
when Ma brazinski you know shuts Joe up
long enough to [__] go after someone
like Chris Christie because that's the
truth with this ma clip if Joe Scarboro
was in on this clip oh my God he'd have
been bowing down and kissing Christy's
ass and all kinds of [__] [__] Joe
Scarboro [__] him [__] him [__] him [__]
him [__]
him ma did a decent job this morning
with Chris
Christie and and dissecting his lies at
the debate which honestly if you watched
the debate you wasted your [__] time
I I know I'm going to show a couple
Clips but honestly it's the same old
stupid [__] I mean the only the only
thing I really derived out of the clips
I watched from the uh the debate last
night is a Chris Christie is a dumb [__]
and we shouldn't be making him a hero b
Nikki Haley is IR irrelevant as she
[__] should be and see I cannot wait
for be ramaswami to be Andrew
yanged he be has such a [__] Andrew
Yang vibe to him you know what I mean oh
you remember Andrew Yang you remember
that [__] guy he get up on stage and
say some crazy [__] he say some weird
[__] people like what the [__] is he
talking about what the [__] is he
talking about and and some people like
yeah I'm in the Yang gang because he's
cool I don't know why but he's [__]
cool okay he's not that cool he's kind
of a bonehead he is a bonehead Andrew
Yang I don't know if you know this
Andrew Yang is
irrelevant in American politics remember
that [__] tried to run for New
York city mayor you remember that he
tried to run for president he got he got
popular with the Yang gang you know what
I mean and then he tried to run
for mayor of New York and they're like
who who's this guy is he from New York
who is this [__]
yeah I can't wait for VC Rob ra Ren
noodles to be U tossed into the the
trash bin of history and Andrew yanged
finally so those are the three things
that I took from the clips that I
watched oh yeah and Ronda santis can't
walk in high heels I would be derelict
of my duty if I made sure that we did
not make fun of Ronda santis here on
this show because we definitely don't
want to make fun of Ronda santis wearing
high heels and dressing and drag he had
plenty of makeup on last night he had
tons of hairspray in his hair I'm sure
he had a girdle on and he definitely had
those high heel lift boots on and he
could barely walk in them you know
walking around in Ronda santis drag on
the stage is a difficult task especially
when you're some sort of [__] Android
is it real or is it AI [__] I don't know
it's Ronda santis what do you want from
me this is 2023 how can we
tell so maybe those are the four things
that I took from the I didn't watch that
[__] you shouldn't watch that [__] I
don't care which [__] Network it's on
you should not watch the GOP
debates you shouldn't you shouldn't
watch that [__] there there's no
relevancy in watching that
debate you want to know why you want to
know why there's no relevancy and you
really don't have to watch I mean you
want to want you want to know what
they're saying but it's all the same old
[__] it's all the same [__] everyone
went and voted against yesterday or on
Tuesday that's what it is they're
doubling down the same [__] that people
went and voted against in said no we do
not want that stuff the Republican party
like yeah you do you just don't get it
yet let me let me let me have a [__]
let me spend all this money having a
debate for us to all the stand on stage
and the guy who's gonna be the nominee
isn't on stage because he's a [__] ass
[__] and he's got to go hold some
[__] rally to try to prove a point
some kind of Dick
contest and he Rambles on and on and on
he doesn't know who Kim Jong-un is he
doesn't know who the [__] leader of
Hungary is or where hungry's at he just
might be hungry that's it I don't know
Jesus [__] Christ are you kidding me
why shouldn't you watch this there's a
million reasons why you shouldn't watch
this
trash but the main reason is is that
Tuesday this week this week on Tuesday
there was an actual poll like a real
[__] poll not the stupid [__]
polls they keep trying to sell us in the
media a real poll that was taken in Ohio
in Virginia in Pennsylvania in Kentucky
real [__] polls all around the
country and they told Republicans to get
[__] hey hey your policies Republicans
you can get [__] that's what they said
that's what the polls said literally
that I mean you know it's what it should
the polls should be is how do you feel
about Republican policies Eh man get
[__] and they CH that
one oh [__] these guys [__] these some
[__] you know I hate to keep running
Victory Laps on these bastards but what
are you gonna do what are we supposed to
do again I I'll point out the rake
stepping committee here they're GNA step
on this rake and we're going to run
Victory Laps on this this is so [__]
dumb what a dumb [__] exercise in
Republican
stupidity James comr
subpoenas James Biden Joe Biden's
brother who paid Joe Biden back a loan
of 200 Grand and they got a copy of the
check hey it doesn't seem like moneya
laundering or that Joe and James are
very good at moneya laundering if
there's a copy of a personal check you
dumb [__] where are the shell
companies that you keep talking about
huh oh that's right James comr get this
James comr did a bunch of property
trades and paid his brother 200 Grand in
Kentucky
yeah [__] this
[__] oh you're surprised that
James comr is a [__] Republican
hypocrite I would be surprised if James
comr wasn't [__] hiding money through
shell companies and real estate deals
with his [__]
family I don't know I don't know if you
know anything about real estate deals
and shell companies and hiding money in
real estate but it's really [__] easy
that's actually that's actually one way
that Americans have hid their wealth and
through their family and passed it from
one family to the next and not how to
pay taxes on it forever real
estate I don't know if you know that or
not you just start a business start a
[__] a shell company in LLC that LLC
owns it and then you just make people
different people members and different
people
trustees and it never really it never
really dies so the [__] family still
control it and controls the interest and
controls the money especially if it's an
incom producing property get the [__]
out of here with this nonsense James
comr you piece of [__] [__] if you're
gonna subpoena James Biden you need to
subpoena your [__] brother too friend
how about that how about we do that in
the rate stepping committees [__] we
subpoena your [__] brother I think
that's what we should do I'm just saying
what do you want from
me [__] rake stepping like a [__]
it's
pathetic it's not
surprising but it's
pathetic this rake stepping committee
[__] every single one of them speaking
of rake stepping here's another [__]
instance that I'm going to show you
today of [__] rake steppers Lauren
bobbert I I have said on this show Time
and Time and Time and Time and Time a
[__] again about Lauren bobert
yielding her time I'm no it sounds
[__] Petty it sounds ridiculous that
I get hung up on her not yielding back
her time properly in a committee or on
the floor of the house during a
debate but yesterday she [__] R she
jumped on a [__] rake because she
doesn't know procedure Lauren bobert hey
people of Colorado the district where
this stupid [__] trunt is the goddamn
representative listen to me really clear
turn this [__] [__] up your
congresswoman not only doesn't know the
[__] procedures of the house she
doesn't [__] care to
know she won't take a couple [__]
days to know the procedure of the house
rules so that she can go debate for you
properly you stupid [__] idiots why
are you voting for this [__] fool why
she doesn't she doesn't even give the
consideration for to know the rules so
she could can debate for you you realize
when you're like hey it's not a
democracy it's a republic
Tony do you realize do you realize in a
republic you vote with democracy with
Democratic votes and ballots for her to
represent you in your Republic that
she's not even doing the bare
minimum do you realize that she doesn't
even know the floor rules you stupid
[__] why are you voting for this
[__] idiot at least at least find a
Republican idiot that is willing that is
willing to know the [__] rules of the
floor and not step on rates it really is
not that [__] difficult to know the
[__] procedural rules honestly most
Congress people rely on their staff to
absolutely know the
rules it's and they wonder why they
can't
govern you wonder why they can't govern
you people who are voting for these
[__] idiots are some just some
dumbass
sheep oh and I'm going to show you a
video of some dumb [__] sheep today
holy [__] I got some video to show you
we also got a great guest today we had
him on a couple weeks
ago you guys were like this is a great
guest Cliff is back that's right Cliff
is back today at the bottom of the hour
we'll talk to Cliff about the rake
stepping um I I think I think I'm gonna
go through him go with through some of
these clips with him on the air so you
can see us you know kind of punch the
bag on these clips cuz these people are
just [__]
ridiculous and it's so fun to goof on
them it really is it really [__] is
fun to goof on
them and you're gonna see and you know
what I'm I'm maybe maybe we'll go
through the Lauren bobber clip how
ridiculous she
is and how insane it is I mean it it
kind of hearkens me back to you know an
event long ago where margorie Taylor
green said that Roberty Lee was a
Founding Father what the [__] and that
the Robert ele statue that was taken
down in Charlottesville was a federal
Monument what the [__] are you talking
about she wants it to be a federal
Monument she she believes that Roberty
Lee's a founding father of the her
Confederacy that's what they're talking
about when they want a national divorce
they want to be a Confederacy they want
to be the KKK they want slavery back is
what they want they're [__] Nazis
that's what they want I don't know if
you're you know up to speed on this [__]
but Jesus Christ they want to
criminalize women's healthare ban it all
across the country the only thing
standing in their [__] way is
democracy and someone like Rick Santorum
says this is the what the problem is
with democracy the problem with
democracy is we don't get to [__]
rule over you and we don't get to tell
you what to do population if you decide
to use democracy to shut us down and to
kill our Fascism and that's just
untenable for us yes the reason why
Republicans hate [__] democracy is
because democracy [__] hates
them get it got it good Jesus [__]
Christ but we're winning you know that
we're [__] winning and the reason why
is because of democracy that's why I
[__] tell you every single day every
week every month every year we have to
engage in our democracy it is the only
way to
win it is the only way to win not to try
to keep fatty off the ballot hey ho hey
guess what there's a story there's a
story Tony was [__]
right oh my God he was right about the
14th Amendment did you hear that he he
outsmarted Glenn kersner too that's
right Glen kersner too I don't know if
there's a glen kersner one and Glen
kersner 3 but Glen kersner 2 I
outsmarted him the mines the Supreme
Court said no you can't you can't keep
Trump off the ballot that's not a
[__]
thing folks we need to stop this stupid
[__] [__] we are either gonna fight
and we are going to [__] win like we
did on Tuesday or we are going to just
act like a bunch of [__] idiots what
what are you gonna
choose are are you are you gonna do this
whole [__] snowflake thing where you
can't handle where you can't handle us
as democracy dunking Donald Trump in the
trash again like we did to every single
[__] Republican on Tuesday the only
reason why Tate re
won down in [__] Mississippi is
because he [__]
cheated in Black counties and black
districts he made sure there weren't no
[__] ballots hell judges had to keep
the polls open so that he didn't win by
more that's the only way they [__]
win is if they [__]
cheat that the evidence is there on
Tuesday that's the real polls
folks so you can get mad at me about the
14th thing but I done told you this [__]
and I done told Glenn this [__] and I
would welcome Glenn kersner 2 whichever
one that is I think that's the one
everyone follows is Glenn kersner I
don't know who one is I don't know who
the original I don't know if there's
like a three and a four I have no idea
but Glen kersner 2 I would have him on
the [__] show and I would give him
what for about the [__] 14th
amendment I don't give a [__] about
section three you can get in the
comments about the section three but let
me tell you about the real section that
[__] matters in this country
regardless if Donald Trump's on a
primary ballot in one or two states or
that [__] is taking off a ballot
in a blue state in the general election
we have to do
democracy we have to engage it is our
government it is our [__] ballot is
our [__] Choice yeah and I know
you're going to be like well but Tony he
he did it Insurrection yes I know I know
that I I I [__] see that I haven't
said nothing but that on this show but
he's not convicted of it you [__]
dummies and he won't be convicted of it
in time and I know you want to Speed it
along and you really want Jack Smith to
save our democracy but that's not Jack
Smith's job it's not the Court's job to
save our democracy it's our [__] job
and we did that on Tuesday in Ohio in
Kentucky in Virginia in Pennsylvania we
[__] did that we the people those
[__] voters went to the ballot those
[__] gen Z the Millennials the Gen X
they all went to the [__] batt and
said no no you keep your [__] fascist
little fingers off our [__] Freedom
got
it and that's what we'll do next year
and we'll do it the year after and the
year after and the year after
that and we'll continue to make ground
for Equity equality and diversity and
inclusion in this [__] country no
matter how much they want to Resto
culture wars that we've already won this
country doesn't give a [__] who you want
to love they don't care how the [__] you
want to dress they just want to [__]
have a decent [__] wage they don't
want to go broke because of a medical
bill and they definitely don't want no
[__] goddamn Republican Nazis in
their [__] bedrooms got it real
simple messaging real simple narrative
and it works it worked on tues Tuesday
it's going to continue to work this
brand of liberalism where we're not weak
liberalism is the [__] Beacon of
strength around the world
folks the beacon of strength around the
world it is why this this conflict in
the Middle East is so [__] important
to pay attention to in the context of
democracy and
liberalism it's why it's baffling that
people on the left who are not who are
on the left but do not consider
themselves liberals
somehow con
continue continue to not know the
[__] truth and not know that there's
a lot of Truth at the same time and not
know that Hamas is a terrorist
organization they're the ones oppressing
[__] Palestinians
Liberty even even all the while that
right-winger BB Netanyahu that piece of
[__] is is is [__] bombing refugee
camps at [__] those two things
can be true at the same
time and we have to stand for [__]
Liberty we have to stand for [__]
freedom and we got to know what the [__]
liberalism is and we got to know what it
is and it ain't
weak getting together on a Tuesday like
we did this Tuesday and people going out
and participating in their democracy
taking their day taking their time to
use the power that they have in our
Republic to go to the battlefield of the
ballot to make their voices heard in
that forum and in that way in politics
not storm the capital because you don't
get your way you [__]
[__] to get out and do the thing that
democracies do show strength at the
ballot they did that on Tuesday and
Republicans lost everywhere and they're
really [__] oh man they're upset
about it so upset that they're like you
know what you know what we're going to
to do we're gonna lean in we're gonna
lean well guess what
[__] guess what guess what manga we're
gonna lean in two dummies we're gonna
lean in two just like I lean in every
[__] weekday here on this show Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube go ahead and hit that
subscribe button on Facebook boy our
group is growing over there on Facebook
if you haven't joined the group on
Facebook and get a Facebook page you
should really go over there it's growing
fast also follow us on Twitch twitch.tv
thony Michels don't forget if you got
your Amazon account tied to your Twitch
account to renew and
resubscribe each month over there I also
want to thank everyone who's been
sending shots and vinmo chats let's see
I I think I missed a vinmo chat from
Rico Charles here um
it let me get it let me get it up on the
screen here but I want to thank everyone
who sent shots yesterday it was
and and every day that you guys send
shots I know Nat's girl sent one
yesterday
um she knew I was going to go to karaoke
and she knew I was going to drink here's
Rico here look up the app it takes
screenshots every second and sends them
to who knows a huge national security
issue this is a I'm gonna show you Rico
I I'm glad you brought this back up this
is Mike Johnson and his son trading porn
on this [__] Christian
app they look at each other's porn ain't
that weird I guess I guess Mike Johnson
wants to see what kind of porn his
17-year-old son's watching I'm sure his
17-year-old son does not want to see the
porn the kind of porn that Mike Johnson
looks at the wiener of the house Mike
Crow Johnson um but Rico I'm I'm glad
you brought this up because Eric swell
dunks Jim Jordan in the trash and uses
the fact that Mike Johnson is out there
talking about Christian ABS how he's
looking at his son's porn to dunk Jim
Jordan in trash it's great just stick
around for that for that [__] cliff
so I want to thank everyone who has been
sending shots I've been drinking the
shots I Dr I drank plenty of shots last
night I did karaoke we had a lot of fun
last night um and also I want to tell
you my appreciation for everyone who has
bought the even my dog hates Ted Cruz
merch even my dog hates Ted Cruz there's
so many orders for this and there's been
calls for even my cat hates Ted Cruz
merch and I think this afternoon we're
probably going to have even my cat hates
Ted Cruz and we'll go on and on about
this maybe we'll do Mike Johnson maybe
we'll do Ronda santz hell Chris Christie
Donald Trump we'll put anybody you want
on this on this merch but right now you
can go get your t-shirts and your
hoodies of even my dog hates Ted Cruz
and if you're waiting for the cat merch
just hang on it's going to be there also
I want to thank everyone for going and
getting the tattoo Merch this is the
brand new this machine kills fascism the
Tony Michaels podcast tattoo merch
design that's right I am going to get a
microphone with this machine kills
fascist tattoo on my arm in January I've
already got the appointment and it is
inspired by this design so if you want a
design on merch that is inspired by
tattoo that is going on my arm go to the
Tony michaels.com pan down you will find
the tattoo merch there also don't forget
to check out the book club on Discord
the obstacle is the way Ryan holiday is
the next is the book that they're going
and they're also doing Rachel mat's
audio book with discussions there on
Discord so go to Theon michaels.com
click the book club link I am happy to
have you here and I'm happy to have my
guest here right after this break we
will get to Cliff so don't go anywhere
as they say on the radio don't touch
that dial we'll be right back right
after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reached DC
we was 50 strong in number some patriots
ran out of gas along the way we got
plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Dorita you like the red bag not the live
loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] them
[__] them welc we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show it's Thursday
November 9th and they're still stepping
on
Rees in the House of Representatives and
I have my friend here clip he's going to
he's going to fill us in what he thinks
about uh some of these rates that
they're stepping on in the house I'm
going to show him this
clip of Lauren bobert oh my God Lauren
bobert what a [__] bonehead now you
know I I talk about several times about
Lauren Boer not knowing procedure and
the reason why I know she doesn't know
procedure because she doesn't even know
how to yield back time she doesn't even
know how to yield back she was like ah I
yield no no dummy you yield back because
you gotta the time is back it's it's a a
simple procedure of the house and stinny
horer took advantage of this and I don't
even know if stinny warrier actually
knew that he was going to really catch
her in this trap um but here is an image
here I've got an image um of course
rat's got us a great image of Lauren
bobert um actually jumping on a rake
here um this is this is Lauren bobert's
typical style I don't know exactly where
this was taken I don't know if it's in
her District uh in Colorado where she
has convinced people that she's a good
Congress person or not but this looks
like it could be maybe outside um the
the home alarm but she's definitely
jumping on rekes um she loves to jump on
Rees Cliff I'm glad to have you back
Cliff how are you today
I'm doing well man I love I get in the
mood right just listening to your intro
I'm excited just oh my god dude this is
like uh yeah did you ever watch Better
Call
Saul uhuh no okay well then I can't
explain it to you there's one character
who you no it's just you know there
there's the husband and wife Saul he's
got to break up with his wife because
she's so bad for him that she brings out
the worst in him and I feel like you
bring out the worst in me in a good way
you make me want to rip the [__] out of
these guys
and mock them even more than usual and
that's like tough to do because I'm
constantly I mean bobert I was going to
say she may know know not know how to
yield back time but that's only because
she wasn't watching Beetlejuice at the
time she yields really well then oh yeah
I mean she she really pays attention I
mean to some things of beeto juice not
the UN yields she I'll stop right there
I'll get accused of sexism but if I knew
her boyfriend name sexism well hey hang
on a second you're on the Tony Michaels
podcast no one everyone here knows that
you're supposed to be offended when you
come watch this [__] like that I'm just
saying if I knew the if I knew the uh
the name of her date for the night of
her reacharound of the night I would
make fun of him too I just don't know
what the hell is well I mean who who
would know who his name is um she
doesn't she doesn't even know she has no
clue she doesn't even know how to do um
house procedure rules here is a clip of
Lauren bber just absolutely this is like
honestly this is on brand GOP like
because well just watch the clip here
it's it's crazy how he caught her with a
question here and I asked the gentle
lady to yield for a
question's recognized it's not my time I
ask you to yield I have reserved oh my
God I'm asking if you'll yield for a
question sure she's such a dummy okay so
on the floor and CLI you know this on
the floor you you have to address the
speaker right have now if you're going
to ask a question you have to ask if
you're gonna ask a question just
watching the stupid thing you would know
this by hearing Mr Speaker blah blah
blah blah blah I mean she has to have
seen it we've you know we've seen it on
TV she has to have seen it in person
about 20,000 times and still is too
stupid but you know she had she had 15
times sick her to pass her GED too so
what what are you going to do right well
here's the thing is that I a lot of
people you know because I every time I
hear her yield in a committee I'm like
oh my God it just it pisses me off
Beyond no belief that she doesn't even
know how to properly yield back but but
the point is and a lot of people are
like oh that's kind of petty I'm like
it's not Petty she's a [__] Congress
person she what the [__] are you talk so
you're saying that the people they teach
in Congress School these days huh well
well I mean the thing is is like how the
[__] do you expect you're going to elect
someone who's who doesn't even take a
couple days it wouldn't take her a
couple days to go through with someone
who knows the procedures and walk
through exactly what the procedures are
and how it works she doesn't have to be
an expert like Daniel Goldman Daniel
Goldman so so many times uses procedure
to absolutely [__] dunk on Jim Jordan
James comr and whoever Marjorie Taylor
green absolutely because Daniel Goin
knows the procedure front back forwards
upside down honestly better than almost
any Congress person that um uses
procedure in a way to absolutely own the
Republicans lies but here's stinny hoer
he's not doing anything special Cliff
he's just like I want to ask a question
to you and she's like okay and he's like
right she's like what does that mean I
don't know alien just invaded because
she has no idea what's going on right so
watch watch the back and forth here the
volley here and you can hear in the
background you can hear in the
background she's talking to probably one
of her staffers that's trying to explain
it but they probably don't even know it
very well but watch ask your question
what funds in this bill are used uh for
the purposes you uh okay are opposed
to somebody help me yeah right give me
give me a Lifeline getting clarification
this is
precautionary so so basically she's
playing Who Wants To Be A Millionaire
right she like I'd like to use my right
I like to phone a friend can I call a
friend can I call a friend he's asking a
question I'd like to call a friend it's
it's so [__] dumb so here's what
steny horn is doing she is proposing an
amendment and here's what Lauren bobert
does so many times and she's not doing
this out of her own bition she's
actually taking direction from some
dummy uh some other dumbass Congress
person to go on the floor and put these
amendments in place so that she can
grandstand which this is a typical thing
that Congress people do it's not
Democrats it's not just Republicans they
use the Ability during debates to to to
to use amendments to make a speech you
want get your your point across yeah
exactly exactly now sometimes it it's
it's a procedural thing um and sometimes
it's a grandstanding thing but she
doesn't even know if she's grandstanding
or she's actually putting in an
amendment that is gonna go somewhere
watch this this is [__]
incredible no idea what I'm there are
Sanctuary City policies yes I understand
I understand what that are that are in
place that are allowing the
ilal such a bonehead so she so again
she's she is grandstanding now now she
is Grand standing about Sanctuary cities
that's what she's trying to do she's
trying to make a point here but the
craziest part is that stany horer is
like yeah I get that you're
grandstanding but I'm asking you a
question and any real I don't know staff
would have this prepared for her because
you know Cliff that's the other honest
truth is that every Congress person
can't know everything all at once staff
does a you know my wife was on in staff
for a while there are a lot of friends I
mean the the truth of the matter is
Staff does a lot they help write
legislation they and the thing is is
that if you pick staff based upon their
competence even if you're a dumbass
which there are number of members of
Congress who are dumb asses they will
help you seem like less of that but when
you're as stupid is Lauren bber you pick
people just like yourself you know who
just make I mean what what choice does
she have because i' I've told the
audience this before is like there in in
Washington and in a lot of state
capitals there is there is professional
staffers that's what they done for a
living they go years right they go to
law school just to go to the hill NBA
staffer because they want to they want
to participate in politics whether it's
uh Republican Party politics or
Democratic Party politics but they go to
school they get their law degree a lot
of times they get their polyi degree and
then they go to the hill to become a
professional staffer that's what they do
but these boneheads could never attract
a an actual professional career staffer
who wants to know everything to use to
their political Advantage for that
Congress person whoever it may be they
they're not going to go work for someone
as unserious as Lauren Boer like a real
staffer is gonna be like no [__] no I'm
not going to go work for them I don't
want that on my goddamn resume that I
was sing for this morning Mor on I'm
going to go work for a quiet congressman
who knows what the [__] they're doing
who who will listen to a staff member
when they say who is not just for social
media influence because I don't want to
be caught in the bif fire you know what
you would think seriously this is I'm
serious about this Tony you would think
that an idiot you know knowing that
she's an idiot and there are Republican
super packs run by people that are evil
they're not idiots they have evil
agendas they need idiots to push forward
for them would find ways considering the
law means nothing to them and they break
the law all the time to get one of the
to find somebody to get them a second
pack salary outside of you know their
regular congressional salary and say
look you'll make 300 or 400 Grand a year
please just do us this favor and if you
go work for Lauren bobbert for a year if
you suffer through that [__] you can
come over here to the pack or something
You' think they'd at least figure
something like that out but they to make
her look smart but maybe maybe that's
the trouble maybe that's seem to just
like walk through septic tanks and find
random piles of dooo and say you're her
next sta well I mean it is Republican
politics I mean know you know is the
situation that they're in yeah I mean
you pointed out look a lot there's a
grand standing a lot but there's all
there's Grand standing and there's Grand
standing at this point 98.9% to pick a
random figure of what Republicans do is
Grand standing they don't have any
actual policies there's the border is
crazy okay what's your policy for it I
have nothing you know like they're like
oh we we we need to lower taxes what's
your specific policy I don't know I mean
they don't they don't do policy anymore
so you're there mostly to grandstand so
if you don't have a staffer who has a
freaking clue you're as you you're
completely lost and she's been
completely lost during every stage of
her development as a human and I use
that term loosely well there's another
minute of this clip and this is exactly
what you just said happens in this clip
watch this and and stenny Hy is actually
he's kind of taken off guard here that
he tricked her when he his intent wasn't
it's it's amazing watch this and there
is an influx in crime and drugs I
understand in these cities and there's
no there's no way for these folks to
even report what is taking place because
they are protected under this fake
policy that has been created that is
subduing the actual rule of law that we
have in the Constitution of the United
States I understand that but what you
he's like he's I understand that you
want to puke up word salad all your
gobbley
good Congress actually works right you
just said nothing you just said nothing
I understand that but what is it
actually that you're trying to say of of
the actual appropriated funds like
because she's trying to make a point
about money and he's like okay so what's
your point about the money watch this
said to her he should have said oh can I
say one thing he should have said like
listen I I'm pretty confident you'll
regain the ability to speak if maybe we
we right now just screen a couple of
scenes from Beetlejuice so should we do
that that would have been hoyer's
awesome moment right could she could
have Juiced the beetle I guess is what
you're saying maybe maybe he could have
set that up for well let's let's see how
he sets it up here because he really I
think he's baffled about how stupid this
person is I mean he knew she was stupid
but he's like what the hell how and then
there's experiencing right right here it
is it said is none of the funds in this
bill can be spent for that objective and
that is precaution
what funds are in this bill to be spent
for that objective I I have seen this
Administration use all sorts of funds to
protect illegal aliens claiming my time
Ure that it will not be we're claiming
my time there are no funds in this
bill to do
that so this is just an opportunity for
you to stand and perhaps speak about an
important subject I understand that but
there are no funds in this bill to
accomplish that objective um you don't
believe the chairman would put funds in
to accomplish that objective do you like
he's like what the hell are you talking
about why are you presenting an
amendment and and then you can't even
answer my question because honestly in a
real debate in Congress they would never
ever consider putting this amendment
forward about the appropriations of the
funds of something that is not
appropriated a thing that is not
appropriate funds for because a Democrat
would come to the floor knows what the
[__] they're doing and make a fool of
them to ask this question they would
never do that you just wouldn't do that
in real Politics the problem is Cliff is
that people who vote for Lauren bobbert
or follow her on Twitter or look at her
[__] her her true Social account
where only fans or whatever whatever
whatever the hell they're juicing the
beetle over there on the Lauren
bower.com here's the thing is
that the reason why she can do this and
get away with this and this effect does
not have or it doesn't have the effect
on them of what stiny horer just did is
because they don't pay attention to what
Lauren Bower's doing on the house floor
they don't give a [__] they don't care
why the constituents that vote for her
don't care about what she's doing on the
house for baffles me but they don't give
a [__] and the reason why just enough of
them and only by 534 votes if memory
serves yeah something like won her last
election by are dumb enough or are as
dumb as her or Dumber right it's like
the old George Carlin line about you
ever notice that how dumb the average
person and then realize half the people
are [__] dumber than that uh those
those are the people that vote for
Lauren bber but you know Adam frish ran
a great campaign last time he is I
believe a lawyer he was a city
councilman in the area there he ran a
great campaign he's smart he's he fits
the district well and I think there will
be enjoy your little Lauren bobbert
episodes everybody because I think she
will be gone definitively she's pulling
this crap the difference is is margorie
Taylor green as just gross and stupid as
she is he's from like a plus 20
something Trump District we all just saw
what happened the other night in
Kentucky in Ohio and Virginia right
bobert's only from a plus six Republican
District but she acts like she's in a
plus 20 Trump district and doesn't
realize that she well underperforms that
plus six which is why she almost lost
last time and she has even done more
embarrassing stuff obviously since then
so she's toast we we're going to have to
pay more attention to like other idiots
like Matt Gates and margerie Taylor
green and others who are plus 20
districts who honestly it's almost
impossible sadly for them to lose they
can lose but they'd have to go to prison
to lose you know what's you know what's
great about what you just said because I
I've got a margerie Taylor green clip
right here um to go to Mar you're not
exactly and it's and it's a current one
like it's within the last 24 hours she
does so much stupid stuff that you could
play as many of Marg Taylor green Clips
as you wanted and they wouldn't be 48
Hours old now here's the thing here's
the thing is why it is so important that
we point out Lauren bobert uh just what
you said over you know Matt gats and
margorie Taylor green really and
Democrats putting a lot of lean into uh
a district like Lauren boards in
Colorado because we're talking 500 votes
and and whoever runs against her Frisk
is run against her again um he was so
close just just over 500 um is what
Lauren bobber beat him by and he
actually conceded to that he there was a
recount and he was like oh yeah I lost
it's funny how that works in politics
but you know he's a serious serious
person right right he's a serious person
so the people of Colorado if they do you
know pluck their heads out of their ass
in that District those five six hundred
people and elect Adam they'll actually
get a representative who knows how to I
don't know a procedure on a house floor
but speaking of
someone this one sadly will probably be
around for a while so you know what you
know what I can't tell you how um gross
and vile she is and really honestly
though she gives me a lot of good
content on the show I'm I'm not going to
lie I'm not going to lie there her for
that mountains mountains of content no
more workout videos of hers right after
I've eaten right right well you know the
petty Yeti as as we call her here um on
the Tony Michaels yeah the petty Yeti
she's the petty Yeti Marjorie Taylor
hoof foot green um here she is trying
she she's been trying to lower people's
salaries to a dollar and now she's gonna
in meech or maybe it's with her it's in
peach Tree dish why can't she spend that
time just on trying to grow a fourth toe
on each I mean well or or just like um
you know reading what the Bible actually
says that'd be great too oh my God yeah
that Jesus guy he said some different
things than what you're thinking Marge
right right well let's listen to what
she who she wants to impeach tree dish
this
time impeaching Alejandro Nicholas
mayorca Secretary of Homeland Security
for high crimes and misdemeanors resolve
that Alejandro Nicholas mayorcas
Secretary of Homeland Security is
impeached for high crimes and
misdemeanors and that the following
articles of impeachment be exhibited to
the United States Senate I don't know if
they know this and I she definitely
doesn't know this Cliff when they do
this like we're just GNA impeach anyone
we don't like because we don't like them
it really does devalue when they're
going to actually impeach Joe Biden like
it totally devalues it they've never got
I'll be honest with you I mean you know
I I will laugh here and make fun of them
and whatever but I grew up with you know
a reverence for how our government works
and for the the best parts of democracy
and you know one of the things that was
like a politically sort of what brought
me in so strong to being a Democrat is
when that that the initial Ground Zero
clown n Gingrich right it's gone from
him to Marjorie Taylor green with some
others in between it's like that that
evolution poster but backwards right you
go from walking to like drag your
knuckles and it's when they impeached B
while he was having an affair he
impeached Bill Clinton um you know over
obviously sex outside of marriage
because they had nothing else they to
catch him in perjury about a
relationship he never should have been
asked about uh after a fishing
Expedition and that's when they devalued
impeachment by doing that this is I mean
this is this remedy for people like
Donald Trump honestly not for even not
not for even other Republicans who've
been bad it is the you know arguably you
could say George W bush over Iraq and
torture yes but it's meant for people
that are committing High crimes and
misdemeanors it is not meant to be
something thrown around like that
because it is a you know it's a break
glass in case of emergency thing and it
just pisses me off so much they but
you're exactly right they're devaluing
everything about impeachment now because
they're just they wake up one day and
they're just she's in a bad mood because
her tantric Mister didn't do his job or
whatever and then she's just like let's
impeach them all you know know um and
that's what we get well again I don't
think it's in
impeachment like you're saying I think
she thinks it's impeach tree dish Min
here is here's the pety yeti here's the
petty Yeti um declaring impeach tree
Dishman on on mayorcas here here's I
think that guy's got a little bit of a
better better teeth to be honest with
you otherwise it's pretty close and if
you look I think this might be AI um you
know we always are questioning here on
the show rather it's real or it's AI we
really do we question this stuff because
it's coming oh man I got I got all kinds
of image here's this one here but if you
look down here this image here this this
ped Yeti clearly has four toes and I
don't think that is accurate so I'm
gonna question this away from those
things I've seen I think she's three
toed right right she's out of Lord of
the
Rings well I want to show you before you
go you got a few minutes I want to show
you an actual series politics stay here
all day if you if You' let me so you got
to kick me off this well I got I got to
get to some clips and I got some I've
got I got some goofing stuff that I got
to do I'm glad I'm happy to have you and
I think I think Thursday's a good day
for us I think we should just keep doing
Thursday every other week or every week
whenever you can come on on Thursdays we
should just I'm messing around with you
I'm all into it it's perfect I'm not
trying to make you keep me like you know
I'm not trying to be a hostage staying
on your show where you're stuck with me
no you got funny crap to get to and I
don't want to get in the way but I got I
got do my style I got to do my thing but
before we go I want to show you this
clip here um now this is a serious
politician so it's a little different
direction here this is HEM Jeff this is
the next speaker of the house um a after
the election next year let me tell you
something I actually believe hem Jeff is
one of the best messagers that Democrats
have ever had in leadership ever in
leadership Nancy Pelosi is a very
effective speaker she was a very
effective leader she knew exactly the
procedures she knew exactly The Tick
Tock of the House of Representatives and
really honestly in our lifetimes she may
be known as one of the most effective
speakers of the house but I say two
things quickly quickly she is she's on
the Mount Rushmore of legislators in
terms of when you talk about legislative
procedure and understanding legislation
and building a coalition she is up there
with like with lynen Baines Johnson and
people like she is amazing okay so that
so that's the first second thing I
remember running into once being at an
event for a pack I was working for she
showed Consulting for she showed up gave
a speech it was like the fifth thing
she' done that day and she had eight
more and she was like you know at the
time 75 I mean she has more energy than
I had when I was 30 so those two things
she's amazing the thing because I try to
be objective and honest about this
communicating has always been where she
hasn't been as good and I wish they
would put had had put somebody a little
bit younger a little bit more
understanding of our current media
environment YouTube Tik Tok how [__]
Works quickly and whatever out front and
this is where I agree with you it'll be
tough for Jeff to match her on on
legislative prowess because it would be
tough for any other human right it would
be tough for anybody but but he is a
he's an incredible messenger and so that
part of it I'm really excited ex and and
he he is always on point here he is this
morning this is only just a minute long
uh so I'm gonna play the whole thing but
he is on point here and listen to the
messaging that he has because I believe
that Hakeem Jeff I don't know if he's
got staff that listens to the show but
somehow the messaging of this show is is
leaking out into the main stream here uh
right in behind this microphone in this
Podium by the way this Podium is not one
of those Arkansas 9 $199,000 podiums I
think it's just just a regular one just
a regular one fly and whatever else
right just a regular one here for AEM
Jeff let's listen they have no
legislative track record they have no
data point of progress related to
improving the lives of the American
people and guess what that's why the
extreme magga Republicans are on the Run
politically that's why they were
devastated in state after state after
state we're talking about states that
are in the red
column and it's because they've got a
extreme magga
Republican problem as it relates to the
American people understanding that
they're not interested in solving
problems in creating a healthy economy
in dealing with affordability
issues we're still ready willing and
able to work with Republican colleagues
in a bipartisan fashion seems to me that
it would be in their best interest to do
so we we we were told that Republicans
would get tired of all the
winning how's that working out no
legislative track it's a perfect perfect
every single word of it every single Tik
Tock his Cadence Cliff I mean it's again
when you compare this this presser with
which in op pressor there's a lot more
pressure on the person speaking than
when you're on the floor of the house
and you're controlling the time like
Lauren bber was controlling the time
there's a hell of a lot less pressure
there because you have control over it
Hakeem Jeff doesn't necessarily have
control over what's going to be asked
and when and where and why and the Tik
Tock but he's so masterful at the
messaging and I believe it's really
really if we can inject that messaging
into into the pro-democracy Coalition um
the way that we should every single
every single day that I think AEM Jeff
is going to be one of the longest
serving longest serving speakers of the
house well I will say this okay um you
as I was coming on the show were talking
about swall well completely destroying
Jim Jordan yet again um Richie Torres
right um oh my God Jasmine Crockett
amazing Superstar she talks you know you
know what I don't I don't want to jump
on you there but Jasmine Crockett you
know what you know what is U I'm from
Missouri and she's from St Louis
Missouri so she kind of speaks my
language like I hear what she's saying
just because we're from the same region
of the world now she lives in Texas now
but she's from St Louis so I I hear it
in her voice but the one thing that she
does that that is so masterful is she
understands that she's talking to people
and she's talking to people who need to
hear her she's not she's not talking
just to the person sitting there right
exactly I'll just say quickly I was
going to throw in Jamie Rasin and a few
others and and and these are the clips
Dan Goldman these Clips are the ones on
my YouTube channel that go most viral
because they are so good at messaging
they're so good at a getting across the
message positive or negative they need
to and then also realizing what today's
media prioritizes which are gotcha
moments and just sticking the knife in a
little bit just like Jeff did at the end
there he knew to make those positive
points but he also knew as you know
somebody does a show and I know you got
to leave with a line a good line
something people remember and that thing
at the end how's that working out with
for you about the mag winning he is
another one so I I honestly think
whether they're listening to you they're
listening to me they're listening to
others like us who are saying this talk
you know don't sit there and take their
crap don't just listen to their lies
respond any one of them who spews this
garbage respond respond with our
positives respond with their negatives
mock them rip them you know and we're
getting better and better we have a ton
of people who are very talented in the
house we just we don't have quite enough
in my opinion yet doing it in the Senate
there's a few of them Brian Sha is
really good at this you know there it's
not to say we don't have any of them but
we need we need a few more of them in
the Senate and we need to get to the
point where we're all most of our caucus
is this and then but we're getting there
man we're getting there because 10 years
ago you had like rarely a Democrat who
would respond in kind and rip them apart
and point out their hypocrisy we thought
we were above that right you know what
we're not above that you can't be
because then if you let them get away
with it and people believe if only one
side doing the talking people will
believe the crap they say because the
mainstream media sucks and we'll never
tell people what's actually happening
well tell us about your channel that you
just mentioned tell us about you and
your channel and where they can find you
if they haven't already um you can find
me it's C Shor C for clef and s c h c r
in in the process of a long Rebrand
it'll get easier soon I'll just give you
a name and you'll be like so much easier
than spelling that dumb asshole's name
whose family got off a boat from Germany
and other places but it's at seor we're
at 29,000 just under 900 so guys 100
let's say 10 of you were to come from
here and to subscribe we would hit that
30,000 so please do we're excited for
that and again you'll get commentaries
every day often four to six minutes
where we just do stuff like I brought up
swell I brought up Goldman we'll show
you those clips rip the living crap out
of them point out why we're doing well
why they suck well mock Margie Taylor
green and and her ilk you know that and
and then I've got so I've got a partner
who does a contributor who brings in
some longer podcast interviews with
people like Jamie Rasin and Sheldon
White House and some of the reporters
that exposed Clarence Thomas at
propublica and stuff like that so a
little bit of everything please come by
subscribe that's the best place I'm on
Twitter at Cliff Shor threads at CD Shor
but at C Shor YouTube would love to have
you there and thank you always for
having me on the rush limbo of the
lefts well thank you well I got one more
thing before you I got a gift for you
before we leave here's a here's here's a
gift for you um it's an image here of
this is apparently inside um the house
Beetle juu viewing where Lauren board is
yielding uh to the Beetle Juice here I
don't know what she's doing with her her
hands there we can't really see them but
can't see them which is always a
dangerous proposition I don't I don't
know I it depends on if you're sitting
next to her or not I mean if you're
sitting next to her you never know I
mean you know I mean it may be a good
night but again I like to think that
maybe you know a member of Congress
could could keep that at home it's
horrible obviously that fedman uh you
know is walking in in shorts into the
Senate but she's playing hide the salami
you know in uh Beetlejuice and that's
completely okay well maybe she should
have been in the hoodie when she was
hiding the salami clip my friend thank
you very much thanks for coming by I
can't I can't wait to have you back on
the audience can't wait to have you back
on go check out C's channels everywhere
everyone we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the the 72 category filing
system makes it easy to organize
boycotted people places and things so
you can find them with ease the large
centered area can even fit your boycott
sign but best of all when you're done
the boycott binder folds right up so you
can take it anywhere so if you're tired
of having a cluttered mess call now and
get the boycott binder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders fille of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show thanks
to Cliff Sher you should go check out
his YouTube channel follow him
everywhere anywhere you can all those
social media those socials that you've
got we're going to get to this ma binski
dunking
on Chris Christie I promise we're going
to get to that CP I'm GNA run through it
um and this how you should treat these
[__] when you're out there out
and abouts H this is how when people
spout their lies this is how you should
treat them but first off I want to get
to this Eric swell clip real quick uh
where he absolutely dunks Jim Jordan in
the trash again of course again I have
to say again because it is again what do
you want from me what am I supposed to
do about it Jim George Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan is a Fess fool
so this is easy stuff watch watch Eric
swalla here so what I'm concerned about
is that we have
anti-semitic posts coming from this
committee and last October the chairman
tweeted out on October 6 Kanye Elon
Trump
those five statements that I just read
to you were from Kanye West who had made
a number of anti-Semitic statements
before this tweet was put up and then
made the deathcon statement about a day
after the Tweet was put up I the
chairman at the time chairman Nadler
many people in the Jewish Community
asked the chairman chairman Jordan to
take this down and it wasn't just
members of Congress it was nonpartisan
Jewish organizations who said Kanye West
is anti-Semitic I don't know what you're
doing but please do not give him a
platform by leaving this tweet up it
stayed up for months
defiantly the chairman kept this tweet
up so Mr chairman I want to be just
today your accountability partner your
online accountability partner and just
go through your social media because
about anti-Semitism we can't allow a
tweet like this to be posted on our side
or your side did you catch that dig
there to my Mike Johnson and the white
Christian
nationalist ah his online accountability
partner I don't know I don't look Eric
honestly I don't know that you want to
be Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan online accountability partner
with this Christian app what the hell is
it called I trade you trade your porn my
porn is that what it's called I trade
you porn your my porn your porn I don't
know what this app's called this
Christian app where you know what I'm
talking about where Mike Johnson here
let me show you some pictures here let
me show you some pictures of Mike
Johnson and his and his son sharing porn
this is what this app's supposed to do
here it is here's Mike Johnson you know
it's uh great to share porn and the
son's like see look what I look at Dad
this is a lot better than the porn that
you look at you should stop looking at
the porn that you look at the church
doesn't like the porn that you look at
you know what I
mean I what [__] you don't think that's
real you think that's you think that's I
I don't I think I don't know here here's
another example of it here's another
example of the my porn your porn let's
trade porn app
um what the [__] you want from me I
didn't say this [__] I didn't I didn't
get on a [__] TV camera and have a
microphone in my mouth and say that I
like to trade porn with my 17-year-old
son no we're accountability partners and
what this app does is it makes sure I
get to see all the porn he watches and
he gets to see all the porn I watch I
mean it blurs it out but you can click
the little button and it unblurs it it's
fantastic it's a great app it's a great
it's the best porna I've got on my
phone oh and Eric swalwell absolutely
dunking Jim I don't report SE crimes
Jordan in in in this way let's keep
going in 2019 chairman Jordan also
tweeted at Tom Styer and used the dollar
sign for Styer to spell his name again
known Jewish philanthropist playing into
what Miss berett mentioned earlier
tropes about Jewish people and money so
this committee should have a
conversation and a hearing about
anti-Semitism but I would first insist
that the chairman I don't know why he
put this tweet up either he believes it
which I hope is not the case or he just
wanted to own the lips and if that's
what you're doing you're hurting a lot
of people people by keeping that tweet
up for so long especially knowing what
it represents and if we're talking about
being your online accountability partner
still have a subpoena in your inbox
that's about 500 days
old God damn dunking on that son [__]
dunking on him oh [__] this is how you
properly dunk on a son of a [__] in a
committee Eric swell does it to Gim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan every
[__] day every [__] day dunks on
this some [__] and he should keep doing
it and he didn't fail in the U in making
sure people know that Mike Johnson wants
to look at Jim I don't report sex again
Eric I know I get your sentiment here
right about the accountability partner
but I really don't think that you want I
don't think you want to see the porn
that Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan's looking at I mean I I don't
know much about I don't know much
about Eric SW I mean maybe would you
know I'm not going to on anyone who
wants to look at you know some adult
consensual porn whatever it may be how
Wild it may be or how Wild you think it
is you know to each his own
but I'm just thinking he might not want
to do that all right is it time to piss
the audience off yet yeah I'm gonna get
to the meek and the Christie um clip I
promise I promise I'm gonna get there
and I've got I've got some other clips
of V Remy that I want to show you I'm
serious this is so he's so stupid what
the [__] and then I got I got a clip of
Ronda santis walking in high heels
because we are not going to make fun of
Ronda santis here we are not allowed to
make fun of Ronda santis because the
shart Army snowflakes are here on
Facebook today so we can't make fun of
Ronda santz we can't do that it would
hurt their [__]
feelings those [__] Shard Army
snowflakes it would hurt their feelings
to make fun of Ronda STIs [__] what a
bunch of goddamn [__]
okay so I'm going to show you that clip
I might show you some clips of Nikki
Haley but she's kind of irrelevant you
know that's how that shit's going and
maybe maybe just maybe I'll show you a
clip of Donald Trump being a dumb [__]
and I mean there's plenty of those and
then also I want to show you a clip of
Joe Biden dunking deucey in the trash um
but first off I really want to piss some
people
off yeah I think I want to do it I think
I want to do it I mentioned it in the
first 30 minutes about this 14th
Amendment thing a lot of people think
I'm wrong about this a lot of you put in
the comments like no Tony 14 section
three I've read it I've read the 14th
section three and you're full of [__]
the Minnesota Supreme Courts thinks
you're full of [__] too all right but
Tony that's only for a primary ballot
man you people just don't get this [__]
you don't understand what the [__] is
going to happen here and you really
don't understand when you keep when you
keep pushing this these ignorant
ideas of of trying to do what they tried
to do on January 6th because that's the
it's the same [__] thing
boneheads you're trying to find a way to
interpret the Constitution because you
you're scared you're gonna lose get the
[__] out of here we're not gonna lose
against this pile of
[__] I'm telling you we're not going to
lose against this [__] if we
engage if we do the things we're
supposed to do and we don't get
discouraged
but I'm telling you this kind of [__] on
the 14th Amendment is going to
discourage voters because it discour
it's going to discourage people in
Minnesota because they just the
Minnesota Supreme Court said you can't
keep him off a
ballot you can't do that guess what the
Supreme Court's going to
decide I I don't know I don't know if
you heard this but our Supreme Court is
absolute [__] when it comes to legal
decisions when it comes to our
constitution
lately and if you if you have some kind
of [__] belief that this Supreme
Court isn't going to do the bidding of
Donald Trump and keep him on the ballot
you are a dumb son of a [__] you just
do not you just are not steeped in
reality I don't give a [__] what side
you're on I don't care if you like me or
not here's the
thing is Glen kersner number two that's
right here let me let me give you here
I'll show you the difference now I don't
know if there's an actual difference I
have no idea now this is not AI this is
not AI I promise this is Glen kerser
number two and he literally has the
handle number two so I don't know what
happened to the original Glen kersner or
Glen kersner went number one I have no
idea I don't know what happened to him
and maybe there's a glen kersner number
three that has a better opinion on the
14th Amendment than Glenn kersner number
two but apparently Glen kersner number
two's opinion on the 14th Amendment is
absolute [__] [__] that's right and
he's feeding you full of a bunch of
[__] he just is he's feeding you
full of a bunch of [__] and I don't
know if you've been watching these cases
on the 14th Amendment fail and fail and
fail and fail and fail
again but they are and they're gonna
continue to fail because it's really
stupid you want to beat Trump you want
to beat trumpism you want to beat MAA do
like do like we did on
Tuesday do you know what really pisses
him off more than anything you know what
really pisses them off more than
anything whipping their asses at The
Ballot Box not in a [__] courtroom or
some dumb case that Glen kerser number
two made a video
about now let me show you hang on I I'm
gonna be fair here that's Glen kerser
number two Let Me Show You Glen kersner
number one apparently this is Glenn
kersner number one so I'm not sure if
Glen kerser number one Glen kerser
number three is on the same
page okay I admit it I'm making fun of
Glenn that he didn't get his handle
right right he didn't I mean Justice
matters but social media handles
don't oh Glenn buddy come on the show
man come on the show let's have a an
unreasonable conversation about this
because it's it's it's
unreasonable really it is it's
unreasonable and I know a lot of people
like Glenn in the chat I like Glenn I
like Glenn he's got a lot of good
opinions but this one is absolute [__]
and it undermines our democracy it
really does it really does undermine
democracy I don't know if you you're
paying
attention but what we did on Tuesday
does not undermine democracy what we did
on Tuesday [__] props it up and shows
the [__] world that we
still believe in Western democracy that
we are a bunch of [__] fascist here
that we will reject fascism here in the
United States that we would reject
American Nazism known as trumpism here
in the United
States it is [__] very
important and alls I'm looking for is is
really if Glenn number one
exist or Glenn number three I don't know
or I'm looking for Glenn number two to
admit that what he was saying about the
14th Amendment is not great oh yeah I'm
not a lawyer people are saying you're
not a lawyer look folks hey look let me
tell you something let me tell you
something let me tell you something
about our democracy and [__] and I don't
know if you noticed here lately because
I think Glenn is a good lawyer I think
Glenn is a smart lawyer he's really he's
wrong on this
issue but let me tell you something
about this it is not hard to be a
[__] lawyer in this country I don't
know if you I don't know if you've been
paying attention to all these [__]
[__] boxes that Trump's been [__]
pushing out and sludging out to [__]
represent him or not but it is not hard
to be a [__] attorney in this country
I I I'm sorry and I don't I don't mean
to disparage the good lawyers out there
because there are plenty of decent good
smart hardworking
lawyers like Glenn Glenn's a good lawyer
he's a good [__] lawyer Glenn knows a
lot of [__] this is Glenn number two to
be quite clear Glenn number two
was a United States Attorney he
prosecuted
crimes this guy knows his [__] why
doesn't he know about the 14th Amendment
why do he know that this is undermining
our democracy why don't these PE and
it's not just Glenn I'm I'm picking on
him a bit here okay I'm picking on him a
bit and the only reason why I'm picking
on Glenn is because I I would love to
have Glenn on the show to be honest with
you and have a conversation about this
because we will not agree on the fact
that this is that this is undermining
our democracy because it
is it
is my my opinion of this is is that
everyone anyone and everyone everywhere
needs to drop these 14th Amendment cases
and we need to make sure that we put all
our focus into what our Focus needs to
be
on which is beating back fascism at The
Ballot
Box
if you believe that this is going to go
to the Supreme Court and the decision is
going to be anything but in favor of
trump you're not paying
attention and if you know those facts
which I know those facts oh [__] that's
going to be what's going to
happen it is going to be bad for our
country it is going to be horrible for
our
country so why even have the
exercise why even do the stupid thing
that would do to undermine our liberal
Foundation it's
ridiculous it's
asinine and yes I'm not a lawyer but I
don't need a lawyer to know that kind of
[__] you don't need to be a lawyer to
know that kind of [__] you don't need to
be a lawyer to know what Glen kersner
number two I don't know about number one
or number three but Glen kerser number
two you don't need to be a lawyer to
know that what he's saying about the
14th Amendment will undermine our
democracy it's not an Insurrection it's
not a coup
attempt but it
is searching for a legal
Theory because you're scared you're G to
lose and that's not good for Liberal
democracy it's not no matter how you
shake it no matter how you want to pin
it up no matter what the outcome is even
if you keep him off one or two ballots
where he's gonna [__] He's G to lose
in
Colorado he's gonna lose in Colorado
there ain't no [__] reason to go
through the mechanisms and and undermine
our [__] liberal democracy for one
stupid fat
[__] that we can
beat it's not about the law someone's
saying Melinda here in Arizona it's not
about the law that's what I'm telling
you you that's what I'm telling you the
Minnesota Supreme Court if it's about
the law then you would agree it's a
bunch of [__] because the Minnesota
Supreme Court just said it's a bunch of
[__] all the courts so far has said it's
a bunch of [__] so if it's about the law
then you would agree with me not with
Glenn number two again I'm not sure what
Glenn number one or Glenn number three
thinks but Melinda I appreciate your
descent and I appreciate that you're
thinking about this and that's the main
thing that I want you to do is
understand that I just because we
disagree on this issue or I may disagree
with Glenn number two right number two I
don't again I'm not sure where one
stands or the original or three or four
I don't even know if there's five or six
Glenns I have no idea I just know Glenn
number two is the one to put the video
out why can't he secure a decent handle
I don't know but anyways but Melinda I
appreciate your descent and I appreciate
everyone's descent in the chat it's
important that we have this [__]
conversation because you know what the
right didn't do when Trump lost and they
couldn't admit he lost they they
couldn't have those conversations with
each other they couldn't they couldn't
look at each other and go yeah he
[__] lost like this is ridiculous why
are we listening to Rudy Giuliani
standing outside Four Seasons
Landscaping with [__] [__] leaking
out of his brain and listen to someone
talk about voting machines that Hugo
Chavez invented when he's dead and some
satellites and space lasers and Italian
ballots and all kinds of weird ass [__]
they couldn't even have conversations
about that dumb
[__] they couldn't they couldn't we can
that's the important part here about
this 14th Amendment thing is we can have
a conversation here on the Tony
Michael's podcast about this and that's
why I bring it up that's why when every
single one of these these 14th Amendment
cases lose I'm going to goof on Glenn
and the reason why is because it gets
you in a position where you're going to
disent and you're going to think about
this issue it's important that you think
about this issue this is an important
[__] issue almost almost more
important um than the issue of Lauren
bobert not knowing procedure almost is
important it's really important for your
Congress person to [__] know floor
procedure kinda I mean if they're going
to go represent you I don't know on the
floor of the house they might want to
know the procedure they just might but
Melinda I appreciate your descent
that's one thing that that's one thing
that this audience will never will will
will never have me do is turn away
descent because I believe in descent I
think that's what [__] them's about I
mean literally the phrase [__] them is a
protest phas and [__] them [__] them I
don't
care what's
descent that's what this show's about
that's what this attitude's about that's
what I think the new brand of liberalism
is
about that's what makes makes it easy
for Eric swall to make a fool of Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan what it's
what makes it easy to for stenny Hoyer
to catch Lauren bobert off guard because
he wants to ask a
question it's what makes this [__]
country great is descent we can descent
here it is our [__] right it is our
duty as a matter of fact to descent and
to challenge people's ideas and to
challenge someone when they have
conviction
because we should be able to con defend
our ideology we should be able to defend
our
positions and you should be able to
defend your positions and your ideology
easily and that's what this shows about
like Shaz he's an idiot and The Shard
Army they're [__] idiots Bon heads
but if they watch this show enough they
might discover that they can't defend
their positions and because they're
indefensible maybe they should think
about changing their world view so that
way it's easier to defend their ideology
and their worldview and their positions
it's the whole [__]
point it's how it works so Melinda in
Arizona I appreciate you and I
appreciate everyone who's a denter about
this issue of Glenn number two again I'm
not really sure this Glenn number two I
don't know Justice matters but again
social media handles apparently don't
man
oh god oh [__] Glenn seriously come on
the show um we'll have a conversation
about it we let you
uh I I'll let you I'll let you defend
your position H but I'm not GNA stop
making fun of you because of the Glenn
number two thing sorry buddy all right
let's can we move on now can we move
on mc mc Stefan says who is Glenn number
one I don't know I don't know who Glenn
number number one is I have no idea do
you want me to show Glen number one
again here I'll I'll I'll pull up Glen
number one this is this is apparently
Glen number one right here this is Glenn
number one this is Glenn kersner number
one um that's who that is and then this
is Glenn kersner number two here so they
kind of look the same I think they're
the same guy right now this is not AI
this is these are real things this is
really Glenn kusher number two I'm not
making this stuff I wouldn't I wouldn't
[__] you you're my favorite
turd all right let's see here um we're
gonna we're gonna go to the me clip but
one more thing on this 14th Amendment
because U we got what is this here this
is here's a 14th Amendment right here
apparently we the people 14 what section
three this is see I've read it see it's
right here right here on my pter on my
computer I've read 14 uh section
three a big step fan thanks for being
over there and goofing uh in the in the
twitch chat we like the Goof over
there let's get to the m brazinski clip
I promised you this clip where she's
dunking on Chris Christie I know I've
been hanging it over your head the
entire time but here it is here it is
here's the ma clip now Chris Christie
last night of course went on the stage
at the Republican debate and lied his
ass off about women's health
and the access to women's healthare and
Republicans wanting to criminalize and
ban women's healthare he totally [__]
lied about it like all Republicans do
because they're [__] Liars well let's
listen here to M MAA push back on him
and challenge his position make him
defend his lies this is something else
you know when you descent and you have
to defend your lies let's listen which
is allowed in your state and last time I
asked well maybe hang
on what the [__] I don't know why I
muted hang on hang on a second let me
get it
here why why isn't it there it goes all
right let's try it again you to like
bring me the case where a woman walked
into a doctor's office in the ninth
month and said I've decided to don't
want to have a baby please take this out
it doesn't happen less than 1% of
abortions are performed after 21 weeks
and if there is a situation like that
it's because there is a massive
emergency so I just think of all the
candidates you've been the most honest
about Trump and election Integrity but
in this one respect I have to call you
out because you're not being honest on
the issue we can debate abortion but
there isn't abortion in the ninth
month M you're the one who's not being
honest I did not say there was abortion
in the ninth month what I said was that
the law in New Jersey and New York and
Illinois and California permits it and
you can't deny that that's the truth
because it is and so and so look it
doesn't you know don't call somebody a
liar don't call don't call Li noton by
the way nor no no no M nor did I say an
honest discussion about the issue well
well let's have an well let's have an
honest discussion about okay I'm going
to stop it there all right so she makes
a good point
now again I would lace this questioning
and commentary from ma brazinski with
the plenty of the f-words towards Chris
Christie Chris Christie would not manage
uh to come on my show and get away with
some of the [__] he just got away with
now um but I will say that m is doing a
fantastic job of undermining uh Chris
Christie's [__] here and this is
what is important that the media needs
to understand and you know what M
honestly again as I said before it's
much better when you leave Joe off the
show maybe that's what we should do is
get Joe off Morning Joe get him off
there and just let [__] ma run it
maybe that's what we should do h i mean
there's so many times where he's just he
won't shut the [__] up Joe won't shut
well Chris Christie too but Joe won't
shut the [__] up and let M just do what
she does best and she's and she's at her
best in this clip now what happened on
the stages Chris Christie did what every
Republican's doing and acting like oh my
God the Democrats are killing babies as
soon as the baby's born they they kill
the baby that's murder that's not
happening okay and there's no
instance anywhere it's a [__]
lie that women at nine months are going
you know
what I've got a name I know the I know
the sex of the baby we got we got the
crib put together we painted the the
bedroom we put all the fancy stuff on
the wall we had baby showers and I know
I know I'm here at the hospital and I'm
supposed to have this baby oh my God but
you know what let's just let's just do
the abortion thing that that doesn't
happen you [__] idiots that doesn't
happen here's how it actually happens
you want to know how it happens and
maybe if you just [__] open your ears
and listen to women who this has
happened to or if you just read a little
bit women's experience who have to have
late term abortions they have late term
abortions because of tragedy you [__]
idiots there's something that happens
and it is a
tragedy maybe it's maybe it's the
mother's
life that is at stake maybe the the the
baby isn't even viable maybe the baby's
dead and it's a tragedy for these
families a lot of these families and a
lot of these women who have to have
these late term abortions they never
have children again you stupid
[__] and they have to walk through
life with this traumatic
event and then they have to sit and
listen to you [__] white fragile
[__] men tell them what the [__] they
can and cannot do and how the [__] they
should and should not feel about it you
[__] pieces of
[__] and they have to do that because
you're scumbags and you're [__]
lying you're [__] lying I don't care
what ma says here about he isn't being
honest [__] that [__] he's [__]
lying the tragedy that these women and
these and and these families have to go
through with these late when a late term
abortion does happen which you're
talking about fractions of a percent of
any kind of Health Care that a woman
would receive that is deemed abortion
Services because that's the other thing
that really [__] pisses me off about
these lies about the word abortion as if
abortion is one
thing maybe you should do a little
reading maybe you should I don't know
ask a woman
who has had to receive Health
Care centered around her Reproductive
Rights maybe you just [__] open your
ears for a half
second and understand the experience
because you don't know you [__] idiot
you're a man you don't
know what's a woman well why are you
asking a woman what the [__] you're
asking what a woman is but you won't ask
a woman about Reproductive Rights which
you have no [__]
clue you have no experience zero
experience with your Reproductive Rights
when it comes to abortion
services this is why you [__] idiots
lose every single time and you will
continue to
lose in the arena of criminalizing and
banning Women's
Healthcare and as long as you keep
making it your entire political
personality which is what the right has
done I mean it used to be abortion was
an issue right and it was one of the
issues that one issue voters would vote
on but it's become their entire [__]
political personality
lies lies around abortion and this one
in particular
lie that Ma here is talking about the
funny part is is Chris Christie is
knocking the state of New Jersey for
having a law where a mother can decide
to kill her
baby all the way up and until it's
popping out of the
womb but he was the governor there for
two [__] terms what the [__] did you
do to change the law but Ma dunks him in
the trash here is beautiful
listen why don't you answer my question
why don't you answer my question does
the law permit it in those States well
that's all I said so I don't understand
what your problem is with that in the
end if that's what the law permits
that's what the people who passed those
laws said is okay is legally
permissible pain a picture about the
issue of abortion that is not honest and
this is a health issue for women and
there are women who are in extreme
situations who need health care and they
should get it we can debate that there
are not women in the state of New Jersey
tring into doctor's offices asking for
abortions in the ninth month it doesn't
happen and and and by the way you know
you can continue to set up that straw
man for yourself to knock it down
because you're mischaracterizing what I
said I am giving you the state of the
law what a [__] what a [__] ass [__]
dude if you want to lie about abortion
just do it just do it you [__]
scumbag stop backstepping and saying you
didn't understand what I was saying no
we understood what the [__] we you were
saying we heard
you we heard you we heard what the [__]
you said you said Democrats want women
to be able to get abortions all the way
up until the baby's six years old or
some
[__] [__] out of here with this nonsense
we heard what you said Chris we know
what Republicans are saying we know what
you're doubling down on every [__]
last one of you are doing it it's why
you're losing
I don't know if you caught on to that
last Tuesday but it's why you're
losing it's why Ohio looks so blue after
being so red in the last election they
elected JD Vance in
Ohio and not what one year later told
Ohio Republicans to go [__] themselves
when they want to take away women's
rights so much so that they enshrined it
into the
Constitution they didn't just vote to
make sure to protect women's rights to
healthare you [__] boneheads Chris
Christie they voted to enshrine it in
their constitution you love that [__]
word don't you when you're talking about
the law Chris Christie when you're
talking about the law how about that
[__] law you [__] box and the state
of the law in those states are that you
could go into a doctor's office and do
it and that's all I said but look you
know that's a lie too you can't just
walk into a doctor's office at 9 months
and be like cut this [__] thing out
of me right now that's such a bunch of
[__] that's a [__] lie it's not a
it's not an untruth like and again this
is my critique am M she should say no
you're a [__] liar [__] that you're
you're not telling the whole truth [__]
that [__] you're a lion sack of [__] is
what you are that's that's what I want
Ma and that's what I want the [__]
media to get to is you're a [__] liar
you can't just walk into a doctor's I
don't know if there's any women out
there surely there's some women that
have some experience on being pregnant
that Chris Christie could ask I'm sure
there's plenty of them I mean there's
only a few women that have ever been
pregnant right Jesus [__] Christ go
ask them and and ask just
ask go ask these [__] women there's
plenty of stories right here in the chat
right here in the chat there's plenty of
stories about a IC precies about having
have emergency
C-sections all kinds of issues that that
center around Reproductive Rights and
why it's so important for women to have
the right to their own health care and
their own [__] privacy in their
doctor's
office and I would I just wish M did a
good job here but I just wish you would
call him a [__] liar but she does
dunk on him here at the end watch this
this is something that you want to
emphasize um get it um I understand the
politics of it and that's fine but it's
not going to change my analysis as a a
political leader really personal
actually for women and you're the one
who's going to lose on this issue if
you're not honest about it so I I mean
listen you can go ahead and do that if
you want point out point out m point out
to me point out to me where I wasn't
honest I said what the state of the law
is now you want to deny that because you
know it's miserably unpopular for the
state of the law to be in that position
that's what the state of the law is
argue about how many people are going to
take advantage of it or not I think it's
wrong for anybody to be able to take
advantage of an abortion in the ninth
month of pregnancy and I think it's
wrong for the law to be there oh [__] I
didn't get the end on this one hang on a
second I'm not gonna nope we're not
stopping there I'm gonna go to the
[__] clip where she dunks on him
sorry that that clip cut it off before
the end I've got the clip here though
hang on just a second uh bear with me
here that clip that I pulled didn't have
the end cuz she [__] dunks on him
here at the end this is beautiful here
is is this is this the window oh yeah
okay hang
on I [__] it up it happens that way
sometimes okay here is the clip uh at
the very end of her dunking well
maybe now my computer's running slow I'm
I'm going to show you this clip I'm
going to get this clip and we got 20
minutes we got plenty of time I'm going
to show you the Joe Biden clip I'm going
to show you this um tyt actually did
this one clip that I'm gonna show you of
a of a trump sheep and I want to show
you that the
um the the Chris chrisy thing hang on
hang onang here here we go here we go
here it is here it is here we go here it
is here's the end the stage again on in
December in Alabama and then maybe we
can even get you up there we could
debate the state of the law on this
issue exact don't mess with me on the
law M I know that uh yeah don't mess
with me on how women feel about using
the ninth month argument on the issue of
abortion we can disagree
let ah what a [__] idiot walked
straight into it didn't
he Chris Christie jumping on rakes oh my
God I don't know how many rakes he would
break from jumping on them but godamn
godamn he stepped on that one didn't he
oh [__] she just punched him in the
mouth I want to watch it again let's
watch it again he's like listen don't be
telling me about the state of the law
shaking his finger at her watch this
watch this [__] dip [__] the law this
issue but don't mess with me on the law
M I know that yeah don't mess with me on
how women feel about using the ninth
month argument on the issue of abortion
we can disagree let
me I'm not I'm not I swear I'm not I'm
not I'm
not so Ma I I my critique is is that you
should have called him a [__] liar
and in exact way that's what I would
have I would have made it bleep it
you're a [__] liar that's how I would
what I would say if Chris Christie was
here on the show I would call him a
[__] Li you're a [__] liar but Ma
there at the
end oh my God so we need to keep Joe
Scarboro apparently we need to keep Joe
Scarboro
um we need to keep him off the show and
keep ma out front body
slamming [__] fascist and body
slamming
Liars like Chris Christie here that's
[__] fantastic I told you would like
that clip am ma absolutely
destroying Chris Christie so let's go to
let's go to last night's debate oh I
want to show you let's see this one here
this one here is
a a v ramaswami now I I'm tell you this
is um do I want to show this one yeah
let's do this one and then I'll and then
and then I'll tell you about what he
said about Canada
here's listen to this [__] [__]
listen resign I will turn over my yield
my time to you and fr people cheering
for losing the Republican part who's
moderating this
debate we have 10 times the viewership
asking questions that
voters
theat oh my
God so this guy he's definitely not
trying to be like Trump no way no how
but he definitely wants Tucker
Carlson Joe Rogan and Elon Musk to
moderate a political presidential debate
what the [__] are you talking about okay
VC tell tell me that you're trying to
get in good with the simps without
telling me you're trying to get in with
this good with the
simps what a [__] [__] then this
stupid son of a [__] goes on to say
that he wants to build a wall listen to
this he wants to build a wall on the
Canadian
border I'm not [__] you he said he
said no I'll show it to you [__] it I'll
just show it to you he said he wants to
build a
wall he wants this this is [__] lar
he wants to build the wall on the
[__] border of Canada all right let
let's go with it a good relationship
with that next president of Mexico we'll
use our own military to seal our own
military what we need to do is stop
using our military to protect somebody
else's border Halfway Around the World
when we're short right here at home get
serious about protecting this border and
then the other thing that hasn't been
discussed is the northern border I'm the
only candidate on the stage as far as
I'm aware who has actually visited the
northern border there was enough fenel
that was captured just on the northern
border last year to kill 3 million
Americans so we got to just skate to
where the puck is going not just where
the puck is don't just build the wall
build both walls
can't what the puck what the puck is he
talking about what the [__] uh some
people are complaining that I'm talking
over these clips there's intention there
you don't need to hear what this some
[__] is saying it's it's fun to laugh
at him trust me when I say this
everything everything that re ramaswami
says is absolute [__] word salid and
it's designed to collect the internet SS
to his little social media pages I don't
know if you know that that's why Elon
Musk loves him that's why Tucker Tucker
Carlson and and [__] Joe Rogan what
the [__] is this guy talking about and
he's going to build a wall on the
Canadian border I don't know if he's
looked at a
map of the northern border to Canada and
then he goes on to say the reason why he
wants to build a border is because
they're stopping Fentanyl in ports of
Entry what a [__] idiot so literally
this guy is saying out loud that we are
successful at stopping fitall coming
through the uh border wall as if you
want to call it that it's a Port of
Entry it's a big wall with a [__]
gate in it that they open it up and they
spe and they stopping fentol from coming
in our country from the northern border
he admitted that in the [__] little
diet tribe that he had but he wants to
he wants to build a
wall H I wonder if Canada's gonna pay
for this son of a [__] that's all I
want to know what the [__] is going on
with these son [__] oh my God they
just can't step got stepping on R oh but
speaking of that uh it sounds like we've
got it sounds like we've got a a picture
here of Chris Christie stepping on ranks
boy rat you've been I tell you what you
have been on it today with these images
getting these images look at all these
broken rakes that Chris Christie's
jumping on holy [__] yeah thank you very
much I'm I'm really happy that you've
been getting the U every everyone loves
you the audience loves all the all the a
now I have to admit some of the audience
like Tony stop with the AI stop with the
AI enough of the
AI I
disagree I think we need to lean into
this AI stuff you know they did a story
I don't know if you watch this on MSNBC
they did a story the other day on MSNBC
which a lot of the audience watches and
they were talking about the importance
of AI there was also a clip of Jordan
klepper and John Hilman on the circus
they were like they someone was being
telling them about AI how important was
in the 2024 election and they were
baffled and they're also baffled by
these deep fakes I'm like look folks
this is important and I know I rat's
hard work here is making sure that
people
wear is it real or is it
AI That's a great tune that's a great
version of is it real or is it AI so we
appreciate all your hard work here rant
with the um with the AI so get get back
in your laboratory and go you know cast
your spells and do your magic do your
magic in case Trump chokes on a
cheeseburger what what was that what did
you what debate for yeah you know in in
case Trump chokes on a cheeseburger this
that's true that's true it is it that's
what this debate was last night you know
I think that's the audio of Lawrence o'
Donal I'm glad you brought that up right
um and and this debate last night was in
case Trump chokes on a cheeseburger now
it's funny that Lawrence O'Donnell would
say that on msnbc's coverage of the
debate here that was on NBC's news the
reason why is because he kind of stole
my
line I you know I've said for a long
time that people at MSNBC people at Fox
there's producers all around the country
that are watching this show and time and
time again people send me clips of what
they're saying on some of these K
because I don't watch this [__] I don't
I don't I don't go watch Fox News I
don't go watch MSNBC or watch C every
once in a while I admit I watch Morning
Joe I gotta keep tabs on Joe Scarboro
right rant I mean I gotta keep tabs on
that [__] we can't yeah we can't
let him get away with
[__] especially when he's doing [__]
like propping up you know Republican
ideas did you know that he used to be a
and he's still a republican he's acting
like he's not a republican but he's
still a republican did you know that
yeah some [__] thanks rat for all your
hard work here at the show on the AI get
get back in the laboratory get back in
the laboratory find us some more and
great stuff okay speaking of great stuff
I got a great clip for you
here and you know actually I got a
couple of good things for you here I'm
not gonna lie here's here's a here's
this is an image of Joe Biden this
morning U talking about oh let's let's
zoom out here so you can see he says
here's to your shitty ah godd damn it
here we'll do this here's to your shitty
polls this was Joe Biden making cheers
this morning to you here's to your
shitty polls
is it real or is it AI [__] I don't know
it looks real to me looks real to me all
right um here's a here's a clip of dark
Brandon just dunking Peter Ducey in the
trash speaking of Fox News here listen
to
this why did you strike Iran's
revolutionary guard they struck up and
president bid why H them
again up why do you think it is in this
election
season it's a good one I got two good
ones why do you think it is that people
should be more concerned about abortion
access than your
age I don't think it's a
comparable why do you think it is that
you're trailing Trump and all these
swing safe the PS suck here's to your
polls and here I give you the guy with
the last name
Sanchez it's Thursday Thursday Thursday
and we all know what Thursday is after
the Tony Michels podcast it's what was
that live with the guy with the last
name San JZ how are you my friend I'm
good I'm good did you did you see the
Peter Dey question there I I did why are
people more concerned about I don't know
like Women's Healthcare and their rights
to privacy than your age what what the
[__] it's kind of crazy when they're
like oh you know all these polls say
that Biden's trailing Trump and all
these policies that Biden the Democrats
are pushing is not popular the polls the
polls right the polls and then again you
have another election where it proves to
be the complete opposite because God
forbid the polls are not
accurate and people are unwilling to
accept the reality that polls are
Antiquated outdated so not in tune with
what the majority of people want are you
saying polls suck are you saying they're
shitty I'm saying the only polls that
don't suck are the ones you dance on
okay okay hey that's those are good
polls I'm not gonna lie those are
normally those polls pay the bills right
they do they do and you know what the
the only polls that matter besides the
ones that you dance on are the are the
ones on on Election Day those are the
polls those those ones at The Ballot Box
so here's here's here's to your shitty
polls as dark Brandon says there but
what I was saying was I think it's funny
that Republicans and you know Democrats
alike are always or the you know Legacy
Media or whatever are like oh the polls
this the polls that Biden is trailing
he's not popular you know we need an
alternative we need we need [__] Jank
all right uh but what you find is that
we need Jank are you talking about that
guy from dyt yeah man I he seems to be
running for president he's got a whole
website it's not great is he gonna is he
gonna is he gonna um
win uh maybe in a in a world that is not
here uh in a reality I mean he still has
he would he would have to again he would
have to fight this case in the Supreme
Court to actually get on the ballot so
right anyway it seems a little
ridiculous I'm not gonna lie it seems it
seems kind of far-fetched I'm not saying
that you know naturalized citizens
should not have that option but uh it
doesn't you also have to have like a
certain level of popularity and uh
maybe household name kind of uh presence
when it comes to running as a candidate
and you also have popular opinion or or
policies but when you look at
Republicans and Democrats and others who
like oh Biden should resign he should
not go for the second term he needs to
remove
himself it's interesting to look at the
policies that are actually unpopular
Maga Republican and not ask the exact
same question to the guy that is three
years younger
than Joe Biden the guy who is having
deranged rallies Roseanne Bar can't make
it up to the the microphone she's
yelling with a big uh cowboy hat on
about killing who's Roseanne Bar who's
Roseanne Bar who's it no relation to
Bill bar different
bar but she's a crazy right-wing nut who
loves to tell jokes about pronouns
that's basically her whole standup stand
up oh I I I thought you said Rosanda
santis I thought that's what you said I
you said rosand here's here's a clip I'm
going to mute it but um I don't know if
you're going to talk about this but uh
Ron de santis was in drag uh last night
at the debate you can see he's damn near
as tall as VC when he has his heels on
but watch him watch him walk some people
are saying he walks like he has gout but
I think it's he walks like he doesn't
know how to walk on high heels there it
is oh he almost you know man I gotta say
you know I think it was a it was it was
a point that was made on The View
yeah and it was a pretty accurate one at
that you do not attack the drag
community and then go out and wear heels
yourself when drag in Rhonda santz drag
now I want to be clear I want to be I
want to be clear I want to be clear
we're not making fun Ronda santis
because we don't want to piss off the
shart Army snowflakes here in the chat
because we're not allowed we're just
pointing out we're just we're just
showing a video of it we're not making
fun of video is real this is uh
legitimate it's not fake it's not AI
this is the real thing right here you're
watching a man a man who looks like he's
like like he's walking on like on coals
or on glass he's like very sensitive
can't can't put the heel down got only
touch on the
toes and so when you see this you you
have a guy who's attacked to drag
Community when he could have very well
partnered with him and learned how to
hold himself up on stilettos for hours
right you know the other thing too that
I I want to point out here before we
shoot to your show here because of time
about this Ronda santis
thing you know I would imagine that
Ronda santis would say that Joe Biden
isn't qualifying to be president because
he he kind of walks you know differently
and it's almost like it's kind of
projection because he walks I mean if
you really look at this clip I mean if
you really evaluate it you
know here I mean look look at how he you
know he's he's acting like he enjoys
human interaction with the here and then
he kind of shuffles he can't really he's
almost like he's got Gout or he's
old I mean let let the dogs out man you
know they for hours they've been they've
been propped up in that position let you
gotta let those boys howl you know like
on like on die hard you know what you
know you know the secret right when you
go when you get off the plane and you
get into your hotel room you make fist
with your feet in the carpet that's how
you that's how you relax that's the
that's what Ronda sanos needs to do he
needs to take his heels off he needs to
take his heels off do you think that
Ronda Sanz is into like footbinding
like like
traditionaly we're not supposed we are
not we are not supposed to make fun of
Ronda santz on this show I'm not making
Army
snowflakes just ask we're just asking
question asking questions just ask did
you hear your buddy VC wants Tucker
Carlson to do these debates before you
go he said Joe Rogan yeah V and Elon
which is funny because those are all
three sensitive white males that would
easily get
emotional and combative right in in a
situation I think that's what he want
it's funny because v ramaswami v the
fake
ramaswami has created himself to be the
enemy like he has create or he's created
himself to be the villain of the GOP
which is commendable it is good good and
you know I I In that clip I said tell me
that you're going after the simps
without telling me you're trying to get
in good with the Sims Gabe Sanchez right
after this show the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube and twitch go go do
your [__] show go on go on go get the
hell out of here get the hell out of
here get the hell out of here everyone
stick around for gab SES what was that
live right after the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube and twitch I want to
thank you again for being here I have a
birthday I got to get to Lisa McBarron
happy birthday to to you happy birthday
to you Lisa happy happy birthday and to
anyone else out there that has a
birthday today that I didn't get to as
well and I also appreciate you guys
going to Theon michaels.com checking out
the new tattoo merch go over there the
Tony michaels.com and also the even my
dog hates Ted Cruz be looking for even
my cat hates Ted Cruz merch I'll be
posting that on YouTube and social media
as soon as it is up and available in the
store we're also going to get coffee
mugs and everything else for that even
my dog hates Ted Cruz and even my cat
hates Ted Cruz so I want to tell
everyone thank you for supporting the
show that way means so much to me and it
would mean so much to me if he's stuck
around here on YouTube or on Twitch to
go to watch what was that live with the
guy with the last name Sanchez I'll be
here same time same place tomorrow Sur
that
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking